[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
waouh c'est aussi impressionnant qu'un
central de wimbledon
bonsoir à tous avez vous déjà travaillé
extrêmement dur pour un objectif qui
vous paraissait pourtant impossible à
réaliser
mais vous étiez persuadé que vous allez
y arriver parce que moi c'est ma vie et
je vous la raconter
j'ai grandi dans un petit village en
haute-loire de 2500 habitants avec
l'envi la plus profonde depuis mon âge
de 8 ans de remporter ce fameux ton
agrumes bowden j'ai d'ailleurs écrit une
lettre à mes parents pour en mai 8 ans
en demandant pour mon anniversaire
un monopoly des pères pour faire des
bracelets d'ailleurs comme vous voyez ça
ça continue et le trophée wimbledon
alors ma maman m'a répondu ma chérie on
peux t'offrir monopoly on peut offrir
des perles
en revanche ce trophée wimbledon il va
falloir que tu t'entraînes extrêmement
dur si tu veux y arriver et me voilà
donc tous les soirs après l'école à
m'entraîner encore et encore avec une
machine à bâle parce que mon papa ne
savait pas jouer au tennis il ne sait
d'ailleurs toujours pas joué au tennis
avec la ferme envie de réaliser mon rêve
j'ai dû attendre vingt ans vingt ans
pour pouvoir jouer cette fameuse finale
de wimbledon
le 6 juillet 2013 et pourtant juste
avant que ton ça commence j'étais dans
la pire situation ma carrière je venais
d'arrêter les entraînements avec mon
papa
alors ça faisait depuis donc 20 ans qui
m'entraîne et je n'avais plus aucun
staff autour de moi puis préparateur
physique pub qui n'est plus donc
d'entraîneur tennis est donc dans la
panique générale
j'appelle la fédération français de
tennis en leur demandant si je pouvais
utiliser le staff de fed cup puisque
j'avais joué la fed cup cette année là
pour pouvoir m'entraîner pendant le
point de wimbledon
la fédération accepte et me voilà parti
dans ton à wimbledon avec donc un
nouveau préparateur physique
un nouveau qui n'est même pas entraîneur
tennis vraiment juste amélie mauresmo
qui me donnait quelques conseils pour
pouvoir m'aider à gérer mes matches et
la ferme envie de vouloir réaliser mon
rêve
et puis je commence à gagner un match et
j'en gagne 2 et gens gagnent 3 mais je
me retrouve en deuxième semaine
et puis je suis en quarts de finale et
puis en demi et me voilà en finale
ce fameux 6 juillet 2013
et là quand je me lève le matin je sais
très bien que c'est le moment pour moi
de faire basculer ma vie dans une autre
dimension
soit je réalise mon rêve je peux
inscrire mon nom sur le tableau des
champions de wimbledon
soit je perd à nouveau cette finale pour
la deuxième fois parce que j'étais déjà
en finale en 2007
je deviens une des plus grandes looseuse
l'histoire de son sport et mon avenir
bascule dans quelque chose de nettement
plus incertain l'enjeu peut paraître
stratosphérique
et pourtant j'étais persuadé que
j'allais y arriver je joue contre sabine
lisicki une allemande contre qui j'avais
perdu trois fois auparavant
je rentre sur le terrain je la regarde
droit dans les yeux et je vois en l2 la
peur de la peur du stress et je me dis
j'ai vraiment être que ce match commence
et donc une heure et demie plus tard je
me retrouve sur la balle de match je
mène 6 1 5-4 40-0
j'avance sur la ligne j'aime à mal et là
je me revois comme quand j'étais dans
mon boulot de rome à retournac quand
j'avais 8 ans à faire le dernier service
pour finir mon entraînement gère mon
geste je sers la balle qui tombe sur la
ligne
la craie blanche qui montent dans le
ciel et là j'entends des sept matches
nice partent au lit et mon destin a
basculé à ce moment là je viens de
remporter le fond à wimbledon sans
perdre un set
je viens d'inscrire mon nom sur ce
fameux tableau des champions que très
peu de gens et très peu de joueurs ont
eu la chance de vivre et j'ai trophée
dans les mains
et là au moment où je soulève le trophée
j'ai l'impression que mes pieds décollés
du sol en même temps que mes pieds ne
touchent plus terre que je suis en train
de m'en volet avec ce trophée et je
réalise mon rêve d'enfant mon rêve que
j'ai attendu pendant 20 ans je vais
enfin dans les mains mais il ya un jour
d'après parce que la vie ne s'arrête pas
là parce que la vie ne s'arrête pas au
moment où vous avez trop fait enlever un
wimbledon et donc je savais en attaquant
et 2013 que je vais commencer à penser à
ma reconversion
je le savais pas ce que mon corps était
trop fatiguée parce que j'avais des
douleurs répétées qui devenait vraiment
gênant pour la pratique de mon sport et
donc j'avais la chance de pouvoir partir
en étant au parce que j'avais gagné ce
droit
donc la voie toute tracée contre on est
dans le sport c'est de faire des
commentaires sportifs
donc effectivement j'avais décidé de me
lancer dans cette carrière de
commentaires sportifs parce que j'aime
trop tennis pour pouvoir m'en séparer
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je viens de
roland garros aujourd'hui mais c'était
pas ma seule passion
j'étais passionnée par la mode et je
voulais vraiment avoir une carrière dans
cette discipline
j'ai donc commencé une école de mode
cette année là en fin 2013 et puis j'ai
eu la chance d'être invité par richard
branson sur son île dans les bahamas
pour faire une exhibition de tennis dans
le principe de cette exhibition c'est
d'avoir un joueur professionnel qui joue
avec un joueur amateur en faisant des
doubles pendant deux jours et donc un
trophée remis à la fin j'arrive sur
l'île de richard branson j'ai des
étoiles plein les yeux chez obama ce
quelque chose de paradisiaque et donc à
zine et le soir est organisée pour
souhaiter la bienvenue à tous les
joueurs et le hasard fait que je suis
assise à côté juste de richard branson
ya rafael nadal à la table etc et donc
il se retourne vers moi et me dit alors
avec quinze joueurs professionnels on
rate eu la chance de jouer et là j'ai
dit ah non non vous avez confondre c'est
moi qui gagne wimbledon cette année
d'anglais c'est vous qui éventuellement
l'être monde amateur d'ailleurs et le
hasard café effectué effectivement
c'était mon amateurs donc j'ai pu jouer
trois jours tennis avec lui ce qui est
un sou ni
exceptionnel on est d'ailleurs resté ami
cette anecdote vous avez beaucoup rire
et dont kim a pu prodiguer des conseils
sur ma reconversion ou j'ai eu la chance
de réussir mon école de mode j'ai la
chance de pouvoir dessiner pour une
grande marque de vêtements de sport les
affaires de tennis et quand j'avais
l'impression que ma vie était parfaite
que j'avais réussi ma carrière sportive
que mon après-carrière été parfaitement
lancé
j'ai connu le pire moment donné j'avais
rencontré mon ancien compagnon juste
après l'année 2013 dans le début 2014
et très rapidement dans notre relation
et m'a expliqué que tout ce que je
faisais c'était nul
donc il me disait que j'étais trop rose
donc il fallait que je maigrisse on joue
au tennis ans est en vie mais expliquer
comment je vais jouer au tennis lui
était banquier donc c'était assez
ironique c'est drôle et que je
travaillais pas assez dans ma
reconversion non plus bref que tout ce
que je faisais c'était c'était nul
donc je me suis mis en entamer un régime
draconien
alors comme tout ce que je fais est un
petit peu extrême j'ai perdu mes chronos
j'ai fait un régime extrêmes donc j'ai
perdu très rapidement beaucoup de poids
mais comme ça ne suffisait de pas
c'était encore pour autre chose encore
autre chose et tu m'as réduit a
absolument rien donc j'avais
l'impression que ma vie ne servait plus
à rien j'étais descendu à 52 kg qui est
un poids très faible pour moi quand je
voulais raconter effectivement il m'a
expliqué que je ne travaillais pas assez
donc j'avais accepté projet
professionnel sur projet professionnel
et lors d'un énième projet professionnel
en inde
j'ai attrapé un virus sanguin qui
m'empêchait de m'alimenter donc de là je
suis descendu à 41 kg comme vous pouvez
le voir sur la photo qui était un poids
dramatiquement faibles pour moi et
d'ailleurs pour n'importe qui et donc je
me suis retrouvé à wimbledon 2016
avec l'impossibilité pour un jouet
tournoi des légendes où j'étais engagé
parce que les médecins avaient peur que
je fasse un arrêt cardiaque sur le court
et que donc je meurs à ce moment là et
j'en était parfaitement consciente
je savais que mon coeur pouvait
s'arrêter à tout moment et que je
pouvais mourir pendant ces quinze jours
de wimbledon
mais si j'avais accepté parce que c'est
comme si cet endroit représenter le plus
grand bonheur de ma vie trois ans
auparavant et ma perte
trois ans plus tard j'ai pu survivre à
wimbledon 2007 j'étais hospitalisée
juste derrière je suis resté six mois
hospitalisé en réanimation qui a été une
période très difficile pour moi vivre et
j'avais un tableau dans ma chambre et
dans cette chambre d'hôpital j'avais
écrit une phrase qui m'a guidé pendant
toute ma convalescence
j'avais écrit udraw strong world is
being trop idiot en les objets et je me
suis raccroché à sa pou battre au
quotidien pour remonter la pente petit à
petit pour reprendre goût à la vie pour
me relancer des défis et je fais le rêve
à ce moment là de pouvoir rejouer au
tennis mais pas simplement rejouer au
tennis reprend maclin professionnels
regagner un grand chelem revivre ce
fameux 6 juillet 2013 à nouveau revivre
ce bonheur absolu
alors quand vous posez 41 kg et que vous
battez juste pour survivre sa part est
totalement utopique impossible
irréaliste
aujourd'hui je suis devant vous
quasiment prête à reprendre ma carrière
sportive
et le jour où ça arrivera
je pourrais dire j'aurais réussi et mon
message pour vous ce soir c'est vous
dire que à loeb de vos futurs projets
professionnels
quand vous avez beaucoup de doute c'est
que bien évidemment l'avenir paraît
incertain que la montagne paraît trop
haute à franchir que on vous dit que
c'est impossible
en fait les ressources ou les avez en
vous parce que la force du mental et du
coeur peuvent vous permettre de franchir
tous les obstacles que vous désirez
franchir merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]